[Musique]
christian rafa bonjour bonjour bertrand
cariou bonjour à tous vous êtes candidat
donc à votre propre succession pour les
prochaines élections municipales dans la
ville de saint pierre vous êtes en train
d'achever votre premier mandat qui a
d'ailleurs été un peu plus court que
celui des autres maires faut-il le
rappeler puisque l'élection de 2014
avait été annulé et finalement vous avez
été élu en 2015 pourquoi christophe
raffin avoir choisi de rempiler tout
simplement voilà avant toute chose bien
entendu il est encore temps de souhaiter
à tous les martiniquais quel qu'il soit
et surtout au pire au teint une bonne
heureuse et une bonne et heureuse année
2020 que leurs voeux personnels
professionnels et autres se puisse se
réaliser cette année
oui vous l'avez déjà 10 1 la première
des raisons
vous l'avez rappelé que notre mandat mon
équipe et moi même n'a débuté qu'en que
le 7 avril 2015 très exactement donc les
élections de 2020 vont arriver en mars
et nous n'aurons même pas fait cinq ans
d'exercice en ayant en plus trouvé une
situation extrêmement difficile qui ne
nous a pas permis de mettre de déployer
notre notre programme immédiatement
puisque la situation financière était
très dégradé l'outil municipal ça n'est
pas péjoratif mais des hommes et des
femmes qui constituent la ville la
municipalité était en déshérence le
social n'est pas respectée c'est une
équipe qui était de déstructurer dans la
ville y avait des chantiers qui n'était
pas terminée
la vie déteste ça c'est ce sont pas mes
mots mes démos des pires au teint clair
que nous avons trouvé des écoles en
situation dégradée
donc il y a eu a dans un premier temps
beaucoup de choses à faire dans
l'urgence pour remettre à flot se sont
par exemple au niveau du social
les enfants des écoles dont qui avaient
vu leurs tickets de cantine augmenté de
50%
quelques mois avant des élections des
parents n'arrivais même plus à payer la
cantine donc il a fallu traiter tout
cela en urgence le ccs nous avons décidé
de garder 1 30%
encore un exemple mais on pourra pas
faire il pourra parfaire la mandature
avec le peu de temps qui nous est
imparti mais ce que je veux dire bon si
on comprend bien c'est que vous êtes
arrivé le chantier était vaste
vous avez entamé un certain nombre de
choses et il vous demander à la
population de vous faire à nouveau
confiance pour poursuivre et initier
d'autres chantiers peut-être oui parce
que après avoir résolu en résumé tous
les problèmes y compris des contentieux
que nous avons trouvée nous avons
commencé à déployer notre politique en
matière culturelle la ville a maintenant
retrouvé sur la belle ville à 10 soirées
très animées à le cadre de vie vraiment
je suis obligé de vous interrompre il
faudra pas parce que on sait que ça
commence à être un des thèmes la
campagne des municipales 2009 savez de
quoi je veux parler 2021 bah oui les
adversaires commencent à l'utiliser
il ya une polémique sur les conditions
de l'appel d'offres pour la
réhabilitation du musée
franck perrais le musée volcanologique
vous voulez répondre là dessus il ya des
dates qui ne correspondent pas on dit
que alors évidemment j'utilise le
conditionnel mais oui on dit que vous
auriez attribué donc la concession au
moment de la tribu à une entreprise qui
n'était pas encore constitué est bon il
ya un problème de concordance des dates
rédaction nous avons même reçu des
documents qui le oui seulement je
pourrais laisser penser ça je vous
répondais je ne suis pas à 100 de sa la
procédure a été suivie et légalisé par
le contrôle de légalité
attendez attendez le document que nous a
donné c'est que la concession était
attribué en août 2010 8 en août 2010
huit concessions du service public
relative à l'exploitation moderne et
villa saint pierre attendent et vous
allez m'expliquer vous allez expliquer
surtout aux 10,2 c'est dommage parce que
c'est un argument de campagne
c'est vraiment à la réalité juridique
parce que sinon ces personnes auraient
posé la question au tribunal
administratif et jeu au même au pénal et
je serai là s'il a vu l'entreprise vaut
remise en question et s'est déclaré en
octobre 2010 8,7 pour vous répondre très
précisément la signature de la
convention de dsp de délégation de
service public à ces fêtes en décembre
d'accord après une procédure kaka qui
s'est déroulée 18 2018 exactement
décembre 2018
pré validation ultime validation par le
conseil municipal après une procédure
qui a duré plusieurs mois de mars à
décembre
nous avons après toute cette procédure
signé la convention de l'onu
là dessus vous n'avez aucun inquiétude
est sûre du mans faut très bien sinon je
serais déjà je serais le premier à le
savoir bord bord alors pour terminer en
quelques mots qu'est ce qui se joue de
fondamental pour la ville de saint
pierre et ses habitants sa population là
avec ce scrutin qui arrivent mais pour
moi ce qui me concerne et mon équipe cd
de poursuivre le travail que nous avons
commencé nous avons mis beaucoup de fer
au feu comme on dit quand il se dit le
développement économique sera vraiment
un marque de notre programme de façon à
ce que tous les pires haute et en
profitent que la richesse plus qui
émanerait du tourisme sur lequel saint
piat peuvent se positionner à tourisme
émergents dit atout france est citée
site est remarquable savoir que le ce
que nous pouvons nous mieux c'est la
culture le patrimoine l'histoire de la
ville de saint-pierre et là nous avons
un champ extraordinaire c'est déjà une
convention qui se dessine avec le comité
martiniquais du tourisme
on n'a jamais vu autant de deux
touristes à saint pierre en ce moment
mais il nous reste encore à faire en
sorte qu'ils dépensent sur saint-pierre
et donc que la population et que
l'emploi en profite
ce sera l'enjeu majeur mais pas le seul
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
faire et nous demandons la confiance de
la population pour pouvoir continuer le
travail que nous avons entamé
merci christian rafa d'avoir répondu à
nos questions dans son caddie spécial
municipal réalisé par cédric berkeley